[Music]
we love gravity falls and today we're
exploring some pretty impressive fan art
wait until you see a much taller and
grownup version of Gideon give this
video a thumbs up and hit that subscribe
button to never miss another video again
now let's check out 10 gravity falls
characters all grown up
Mabel let's start with the sweetest
character on the show even if you don't
like Mabel you kind of like her this
energetic happy-go-lucky child is one of
our favorites her and dipper are the
perfect pair of siblings and we'll see
them both reimagined as adults we'll
talk more about dipper later but let's
focus on Mabel first this illustration
belongs to the talented SD 99 stuff from
deviantART who did an amazing job of
portraying Mabel's playful side even as
an adult her hair got longer and we hope
she's still wearing some of the most
comfortable sweaters ever most
importantly she still looks like she's
the same happy-go-lucky person that
loves to make everyone around her laugh
dipper we can't forget about this
popular main character of the show
dippers the type of a person that always
likes to get in trouble his curiosity
makes him go on some of the most
exciting adventures ever but it's also
fun to see his serious side this
illustration belongs to the talented
Wickfield from deviantART and it
perfectly represents what dipper would
look like as an adult he looks like
pretty similar to grunkle Stan doesn't
he we're not sure how we feel about his
grumpy look but we bet he still has a
sweet side to him do you prefer young or
old differ make sure you let us know in
the comments Pacifica
let's move on to Pacifica the most
popular girl in gravity falls
this Devo is everyone's least favorite
character until the scary episode where
she had to work together with differ and
the rest of the gang she can be a bit
hard-headed but underneath that she can
actually be a pretty decent person
wild Cobra girl from deviantART
reimagined what Pacifica would look like
all grown up she might look the same but
this version of the diva is definitely a
lot more feisty and we have a feeling
she always gets what she wants even as
an adult do you think her and dipper
have actually developed a romantic
interest at some point in their lives
the girls and here are the three girls
of gravity falls Pacifica the most
popular girl in town Mabel's most
cheerful ones and Wendy who will talk
more about
just a little bit wild cobra girl from
deviantART also beautifully reimagined
what these three would look like all
grown up the illustration is pretty
spot-on
they're definitely older but it looks
like they all kept their original
personalities
Wendy still looks cool Pacifica still
looks like a diva and Mabel is just as
fabulous we wonder if the three would
get along more as grown-ups or what
Pacifica still make Mabel her biggest
rival who just can't seem to get along
Wendy and dipper get ready because this
is one of the cutest illustrations ever
we all know Wendy and dipper are a true
OTP although it's clear that Wendy is
almost too old for dipper and the
different tries way too hard to get the
girl but you are totally adorable in one
of our favorite cartoon couples winter
made an eleven from deviantART did a
fantastic job at reimagining what these
two it'd look like when they are
slightly older check it out it looks
like Dipper finally outgrew Wendy and
the two are truly adorable together and
from what it looks like they're madly in
love just like it should be even though
this show is over we're still rooting
for these two soos speaking of favorite
characters how could we possibly forget
about SIDS he's pretty mysterious and
even the intro the show labels him as a
huge question mark but apart from being
an unusual character soos is incredibly
sweet and friendly to everyone even
though he can be just a little bit
clueless this is what he'd look like as
a slightly older character this
illustration belongs to the talented
cherry violets from deviantART who
turned soos into a strong handyman who
clearly knows what he's doing he
definitely doesn't look as childish as
he does in some of the moments on the
show and we bet he can be pretty helpful
with those tools bill cipher bill cipher
is one of the most intriguing characters
that always reminds us just how
controversial this show actually is you
might be wondering why we're showing it
to you in the first place especially
since Bill's nothing but a triangle but
narrow Sanchez from deviantART
reimagined bill as an actual human and
we really love this illustration check
this out it's bill cipher all grown up
did you imagine bill looking like this
as a human we think is totally fabulous
and he definitely looks ready for some
mischief and controversial moments and
the yellow color definitely suits him
as does his anime look we have a feeling
this bill is a lot more powerful Mabel
and dipper and here they are together
the slightly older and much taller pines
twins that are always up to no good
these two get in a lot of trouble but
without those
town of gravity falls wouldn't be the
same s p99 stuff from deviantART
beautifully reimagined the two as adults
and even compared their versions to the
original they definitely look much more
grown-up but at the same time these two
look like they're ready for mischief
we're still sad gravity falls ended
because we'll never be able to see what
these two would actually look like as
adults and of course go on exciting new
adventures Wendy if you want to know
who's our favorite character on the show
you just got your answer we're pretty
sure Wendy wasn't just dippers and
Robbie's crush on the show she's one of
the coolest characters around and she's
even popular among the actual fans of
gravity falls she looks totally awesome
but we also really loved this amazing
illustration it belongs to s b99 stuff
from deviantART who definitely made
Wendy look slightly older she might
still look the same but we have a
feeling this version of the cool chick
is much stronger even sassier and much
more sarcastic if that's even possible
of course don't forget to let us know
which gravity falls character is
actually your favorite in the comments
the whole gang the gang's all here it's
still hard to believe gravity falls is
all over after the show took such a long
hiatus but were droite talented artists
are able to entertain us with the show's
most popular characters check out the
gravity falls gang all reimagined as
grown-ups this illustration belongs to
me not from deviantART who even added
Norman into the mix he looks a lot older
and much taller than the Norman we know
that so do the rest of them check out
Wendy's short hair and even though
Robbie's all grown up he still looks
pretty much the same but the character
that's changed though most is definitely
our last one Gideon gleeful Gideon
gleeful is one of those creepy
characters no one really likes but we
also can't really hate him gravity falls
wouldn't be the same without his weird
obsessive ways and his confident
attitude nothing can bring Gideon down
even when it should here's how sole
Domino from deviantART reimagined Gideon
as a Crona he turned him into a powerful
demon fighter and it's a look that
definitely suits the power-hungry Gideon
he also got significantly taller which
makes his whole look instantly
completely different it seems like he
abandoned his psychic powers for a new
hobby and even though he does seem
pretty impressive we feel like Gideon
will look creepy no matter what and
that's it for our video make sure to hit
that like button and subscribe to our
Channel if you love gravity falls see
you next time
[Music]